et sur ce plateau michel fayyad vient de
nous rejoindre bonsoir vous êtes
analyste politique et financier franco
libanais michel aoun e reçoit
aujourd'hui les hauts responsables de la
sécurité
qu'est ce qu'il faut en attendre est ce
que ça veut dire que c'est la fin des
manifestations bonne enfant au liban
oui tant que le gouvernement n'est pas
formé je pense que la violence va
continuer parce que en fait le pays est
en faillite et les gens en fait ne
peuvent plus attendre trop longtemps que
qu'un gouvernement soit formé il ya eu d
d d en fait la berbérie présent du
parlement et walid joumblatt le leader
druze qui ont poussé à ce qu'il y ait
des retards au sein du groupe pour la
formation du gouvernement
et ça ça a provoqué la colère de la
foule et saad hariri lui de son côté
protège le chef de la police et tout ça
ça a créé de la tension et c'est pas
près de s'arrêter sauf si un
gouvernement est formé vraiment tout de
suite
justement on sait que le nouveau premier
ministre c'est hassan diab
soutenu par le hezbollah notamment dès
qu'il avait été nommé il ya eu une
protestation dans la rue est ce qu'avec
ces nouvelles manifestations
il va justement être obligés d'agir
rapidement
oui tout à fait parce qu'aujourd'hui il
est le pays fait face à une crise
économique sans précédent vraiment le
pays est en faillite donc il faut des
mesures immédiates pour restaurer la
confiance économique et financière mais
également restaurer la confiance
politique parce qu'aujourd'hui les gens
considèrent que ces politiciens ne sont
toujours dans le déni n'ont toujours pas
compris leurs attentes et leur situation
sociale et dans leur vie de tous les
jours vous parlez de mesures rapides
concrète efficace quelle mesure
justement permettrait de stopper cette
crise au liban on sait qu'il ya il ya
des licenciements des restrictions
bancaires la dépréciation de la monnaie
est également oui déjà il faudrait
reconnaître le fait que le liban
peut-être est en faillite et faire en
sorte que de mettre des mesures qui qui
relancent l'économie du pays
des mesures qui relance l'activité
bancaire parce qu'aujourd'hui tout est
arrêté les gens ne peuvent pas retirer
plus que 300 dollars par semaine voire
même moins certain 100 dollars ou deux
cents dollars
et ce n'est plus viable et je les
sociétés ne peuvent plus faire de
lettres de crédit pour acheter ou vendre
leurs marchandises
rien ne voir rien ne rien ne marche plus
et même les hôpitaux ne peuvent plus
importer des médicaments dans certains
endroits
qu'est ce qui explique que les choses
traînent par rapport à la formation de
ce gouvernement
dans un premier temps ça a été la faute
de walid joumblat que leader druze qui
ne voulaient pas tel portefeuille
ministériel ou un autre ensuite ça a été
le président du parlement nabih berry
qui voulait non pas un gouvernement
technocrate mais un gouvernement entre
qui serait composé de technocrates et de
politiciens on dirait que ces deux ces
deux demandes se sont calmées c'est à
dire d'un côté ou les jaunes belote a
choisi de rester dans l'opposition et
nabih berri a finalement accepté un
gouvernement technocrate et là ça bute
sur certains ministères que certains
partis chrétiens minoritaires réclament
on sait que la france s'est dit inquiète
des violences il y avait eu également
une réunion il ya pas si longtemps et au
quai d'orsay quel est le rôle de paris
dans tout ça la france doit pousser le
bol et les politiciens libanais à former
un gouvernement au plus le plus
rapidement possible pour pouvoir faire
face aux tensions qui sont de plus en
plus nombreuses mais n'oubliez pas que
le liban est entouré de la syrie est un
peu un peu plus loin l'irak l'iran je
veux dire tous ces pays sont en sont en
tension depuis le début de cette année
2020 avec la mort la faim d'assassinât
de soleil manille et du coup ils élèvent
le liban ne peut pas rester sans
gouvernement au liban ce depuis que la
réforme de la constitution 90 c'est le
gouvernement qui est le qui détient le
pouvoir exécutif donc aujourd'hui le
liban un président un premier ministre
démissionnaire mais le pouvoir exécutif
mais n'est pas là merci michel fayyad
d'avoir répondu à nos questions je
rappelle que vous êtes analyste
politique et financier franco libanais